uh thank you for inviting me here and
thank you
uh for coming
um
so today i will tell you about uh oh
can everyone hear me
so today i will tell you a little bit
about
constraint satisfaction problems and
harness of approximating them
but before i tell you the results
i really want to focus on the main
technical ingredient
that will be used in the result
and which may be called an x or lemma
and
this
the study of this
technique
will be
it's an interesting math problem on its
own
and an extra lemma is something we can
use to
amplify the harness of a key player game
and
here is what i mean
by a k-player game
so here i'll just ask key questions to
key players
these key questions are we want to vk
and uh the judge wants to know the
truth of this
k
statements or key questions
and
uh the judge will choose this couple of
questions
uh from a collection m at random
each player gets one question
the player do not uh
does not know the answer other questions
to the other players
they have to answer these questions
independently and
after getting a boolean
answer from each player a yes no answer
from the player
the judge now gets a reply which is a kb
string
and the judge will accept if this kp
satisfy a predicate
or it belongs to
a predicate c
so think of this c as
maybe the question of all strings of
even parity
then the judge will accept if
an even number of players reply one
so the judge is checking with us and
uh and even number of
uh statement is correct
each we want to wiki is like a statement
so this is uh the setting of the game
that we will consider
actually uh
we will
the judge will be more powerful the
judge can ask the negation of a question
instead of asking whether statement vi
is true the judge can ask whether a
statement is false
and but from the
answers from the players the judge can
infer the truth of the statement so the
judge might sometimes ask the opposite
of a question and
uh naked every uh the answers and check
whether
all these case statements are
and even number of student is correct
oh so
uh yes actually uh that's a very good
question all kps they know f sub i so
they can come up with the strategy
beforehand they know that they are going
to play this game they know this set m
of questions that the
judge will choose from
but they all they just don't know uh
what is the random choice of the
questions at
uh when the game is actually played
what are the questions to other players
that's they don't know
other things are public
and
so why do we study this game
as i will explain in a little moment
in the second half of this talk
we studied this game because of its
application to hana's approximation
but
i guess it's also a natural game to
study on its own
so we will be talking about games like
this a key player one round game
and
we really want to understand how you can
amplify the hardness of this game uh
how to make this game harder for the
players
so what do i mean by making a game
harder
we want to
reduce acceptance probability of the
game
maybe the judge is forced to accept with
probability at most for 9. uh
even under the best strategy of the
players
even the players before playing the game
they don't uh they have come up with the
best strategy for the game
uh and they know their goal is to
maximize the self uh acceptance priority
of the judge and still the judge can
only accept with probability of nine
from this game can we
create another game with much lower
access probability
here the accident's probability is only
over the random choice of the questions
that the judge chooses
and uh
so this is uh the question
uh here's a natural
approach to amplify harness
we play the game multiple times
but we also still want to
only ask to josh only wants to ask one
question uh i only want to ask questions
uh
at the same time to all the players
so what the judge can do is uh choose a
number of questions beforehand and ask
all of these questions to each player at
the same time
the hope is that uh
and so for example this is uh
the idea behind parallel repetition
uh in parallel position
the judge will also get a
lp string as the reply from the players
which is the answer to all the all the
answers to all the questions
you hope is that uh the players has to
answer all the questions simultaneously
and this will make them
much harder to
uh
who the judge
and
the player revolution of the k-player
game will also be a k-player game but
not but not of the same k player game
that we have seen in the previous slide
because the uh reply from the players is
not a yes no answer it's not boolean
so uh in this talk we will not look at
parallel repetition and instead we want
to
consider another harness amplification
technique
which is uh
taking xor of this uh of a game
what do i mean by that the judge will
again choose
uh
so in x4 it's like a variance of
parallel repetition
the judge will ask l questions at the
same time
and
the players is supposed to answer just
one boolean answer
which is the sum of answers
uh for all the games
so here's the formal definition of
taking the xor of two games
m and n prime here
uh the judge pick one question tuple
from
the first game and
another question from the second game
the judge then asked
what is the truth of the first statement
x1 with the truth of the second
statement
each player
gives a reply and the judge will just
check at the end
so uh we are going to study
this technique to amplify harness
intuitively um
if we start with a game where the judge
can only accelerate property at most
point nine
and we take the xor of the same copy of
the game many many copies of the same
game
it seems that the players would
have
to to be able to answer
the extra of the questions in this
repeated game the players should
answer all games correctly the intuition
instead
uh has to answer all questions correctly
so the
uh
accidental probability of the judge
should decrease
towards uh
the value the random assignment value
uh
so
in this case the players don't have a
better strategy to
answer
the job questions other than giving a
random assignment
so
this is what we expect to be true
um so here when i consider this
statement i don't even
assume that c is close on xor but
later on i will assume that
uh so the last thing the last strategy
yes you should think of c to
to us you should assume c is a probe to
be close on the xor but uh
when i post this
uh statement here uh you might even
consider cs yeah
not as a group
so i'm just asking if the replies from
the players will look more and more
random
as you play the singing many many times
and ask the players to answer
the sort of uh of all the games
uh
something like that is uh true if k is
one or two for one player game and two
player game
uh you can prove that it is true
but i find it's quite surprising that
for free player games and more
this statement is false and
here is a counter example
pointed out by briet and others
known as the means game
in the
in a quantum
player games literature and this game is
very simple there are only four possible
questions free it is a free player game
uh you don't need to remember the
details
but uh it's so simple that i just write
it here
uh the judge will choose one of these
questions send
these free bs to the three players and
expect the answers to be of this parity
what's so special about this game is uh
if you stare at it for a moment you'll
realize that
no matter what the players do
they can never
force the judge to accept to always
accept the judge can accept with
property at most
three-quarter
so there's no perfect strategy for the
players
but
surprisingly there is a quantum strategy
for this game
using
in some
special kind of
entangled states ghc states
and
uh
this quantum strategy implies that in
the repeated games there is also a
perfect quantum strategy and the such a
grounding strategy
can be rounded to a non-trivial
classical strategy and not real strategy
in the usual sense
that is not random for
and
so
an extra element like this above would
be false
and uh maybe i should pose a question
here
uh
is this is some is examples like this
examples
where you have uh
when you can round this
quantum stress using quantitative
inequality is this the only obstruction
to an excel lemma
if a game
doesn't have perfect quantum strategy
like this
will
the value of the game goes to the random
mastermind value
if this is true i think uh you can
possibly reprove some inappropriate
results
about linear equations uh
without using parallel repetition
but just using xor
this is one interesting question
so
we know that we
we cannot amplify well we cannot amplify
the harness we wish using xor so
are you using uh
a result like this so what can we do
to amplify us uh in the second half of
the talk
i will talk
about hundreds of approximation results
and here is the strategy that we will
use eventually
to amplify harness
it is like we strengthen the
assumption of our game instead of seeing
the value of the game is the most
pronounced to begin with of a single
game is the most popular to begin with
and to uh
we will instead assume a stronger
assumption on our basic game
and then we will use a weaker version of
xor lemma that will be true a weaker
version of the excel element
so we stream that assumption
we want to have a game where the reply
of the first player is encrypted with
the replace of the other players
actually the replace of the negation is
uncreated
it's like one guy is
splitting out a bit that is uncreated
with the other
piece the replies of the other players
and uh we will use the observation that
the correlation of the player's reply
will only decrease if we take the xor
of the game so
um
in the second of the talk the strategy
that we will use is uh we will create
k different games
where
in each game a different player is
chosen to
to be singled out and we will make that
players reply to be uncreated with the
replies of the other players
and
then
if we take the extra office k games we
will achieve a situation where all
players replies are created with each
other
and
uh this means uh
uh amplification harness we make the
game really really much harder
for the players
not said uh
so in this in this situation the
player's replies are like uniformly
random
and this is the strategy that we will
use in the second half of the talk
um
okay uh
why why why uh i i need to justify why
is this observation truth why is the
replies from the players
uh why does the correlation always drops
it can never increase
uh the answer is very simple
uh if you know why it's the same reason
why
uh when we do parallel revolution
the value of the game will never
increase
the value of the repeated game in
federal revolution is the most value of
a single game
it's because
to be able to play all
all the games in a pair of revolution
you need to be able to answer at least
one game correctly
it is the
idea behind this observation
so
all right yeah so uh this is the proof
and
such a intuition is just
the same as what i told you
and
um so
uh we want to apply the technique and x
or lemma to prove what is meant by
correlation between
uh okay uh so here you can think of the
replies from the players as a
kp string okay yeah maybe i should
tell you a little bit more about this
slide we will look at the random kb
string which is a replies from the
player after the negation
by the
judge this is what the judge sees at at
the end of the game
this is what the church sees at the end
of a game
right before the judge checks whether
this is
the reply satisfy a private kc
and
uh we want to say that's
this random variable a random kp string
will be uniformly random in
uh
after we take xor so how do you say that
it is uniform vendor voice random key
string is uniformly random we look at
the fourier coefficients of this
we look at the fourier coefficient of
this random variable
a random keyboard string
is uniformly random if
all the non-trivial fourier coefficients
are zero
so we we need to bound the fourier
coefficients of this random variable of
this random key string
and and that's why we
look at the fourier coefficient at chi
for
this random kb string the outcome at the
end of the game
when the judge wants to check whether
this kb string belongs to a predicate c
and
so we we need to bounce all the
non-trivial coefficients to buy
something very small something close to
zero
and uh
the observation i
claimed earlier is exactly that uh
this fourier coefficient at chi
of a xor
game
is at most the
same for a coefficient
for a single game
before taking xor
and uh
intuitively it means
if one guy replies this independent of
other guys reply
then after tick is taking xor this same
guy's reply will also be independent of
other guys reply
any other questions
so
this is the
technique that we are going to use and
we will apply it to
some harness approximation results
and
we want to apply this to this problem
max csp max
maximum constraint satisfaction problem
so this is uh
in this form we are given
a question of constraints we want to
satisfy max the maximum fraction of
these constraints there are two famous
examples
x3 xor and max reset uh impact 3x or we
have
linear equations with three variables
per con
per equation we want to find the boolean
sum and zero and someone to specify the
maximum fraction of equations another
example of max esp is max reset we are
given a formula in conjugate normal form
we want to find a true for sum and
specify the maximum fraction of clauses
and
one interesting feature about these two
csps i've shown you
is that these two csps are
approximation resistant
it means that uh
even if the incense
have almost satisfying uh have almost
perfect strategy have a
assignment to satisfy almost all
constraints
it is still hard to find an assignment
that is just slightly better than the
random assignment
we so we can always
uh
a random assignment value here means uh
what fraction of constraints usually
satisfy in expectation if you just
output a random assignment
it will be half for linear equations and
seven over eight for max preset
so
in estimated work by hossat we know that
max 3 xor and max preset are
approximation resistance
and
um
one natural question to ask is what csps
will be approximation resistant
in this workshop you will
see a lot more recent developments on
this question
and
to harness results i'm going to tell you
says that
a csp is approximation resistance if it
satisfies a certain technical condition
i call
py's uniforms group here
and this condition will make a csp
very hard to approximate
so how did you you can also have to have
a non-trivial approximation algorithm
to boost your random assignment
and
uh so
i would i'm going to tell you this
result
uh
to give you a sketch of the proof of
this result
using the technique of xor i showed you
earlier
and for now first
i need to define the problem more
formally
so
we are going to consider constraint
satisfaction problem
where all constraints will involve the
sim number k of variables
k is free in the back three x or max
reset
and each constraint except the same
collection of local assignments
so for example if
the predicate c is the set of all
strains of even parity
then we get
the max csp problem is exactly maxi xor
i showed you earlier
another example
if
if the predicate is uh all strings
accept the uh the three zeros
the csp is uh is mass free
uh mass reset
and note that each constraint is allowed
to depend on k literals
not just variables so
the literals can be positive or negative
and we want this feature
uh
because for example in
these literals
somehow corresponds to the right hand
side of linear equations
in x3 xor
and uh
clearly a random or someone would
specify this fraction of constraints the
size of c over two to give
version of constraints expectation and
okay and here's what is known about
such csps
uh so here i have a big ellipse and the
red region represents
some csps that we note are approximation
resistance based on
uh
previous work
before 2012.
and uh it's a small
a small fraction of
csps have been classified as
approximation resistance uh i believe
not even a concentration of csps when
known to approximation resistance
and this is an interesting work
and that shows a lot more construct csps
are approximation resistant
uh this work by austrian and morsel says
that if we have a
predicate if a csp is given by a
predicate c
that is pairwise uniform
then uh
the csv is approximation resistance
uh
what what does it mean to be previous
uniform it means that if you choose a
random kp stream from c uniformly at
random
and look at two coordinates of the
string you choose
the marginal distribution on the two
coordinates is uniform
anything that satisfy this condition is
copyrights uniform
for example
if c is the collection of all strings of
even parities
uh
such a question c is past uniform
because if you pick an even participant
at random and look at two coordinates
the marginal distribution is uniform
so in particular austrian and more cell
will prove the
result of hosted earlier
uh
except there's a cache uh austrian
muscle resource
requires this unique a complexity
assumption known as the unique games
conjecture
and we don't know if it's true or not
so
the hardest result i'm
going to tell you
says that
we we can prove a
very similar result
if we assume the c is not just pairwise
uniform but also a sub group of
c to the k
then
the csv you construct from those private
key will be approximation resistance
uh three uh which one
set three clauses oh uh uh very good uh
that's a very good point uh actually
pointed out so uh max reset is not
previous uniform under this definition
um
but uh
both all streaming so and this result
here
works if uh if the predicate c contains
another subset
that is
payouts uniform so for example max
freeset
uh
will contain
uh this next reset
here contains
the first example
uh
well contains all strings of all
priorities rather than even priorities
and which makes max reset uh
approximation resistance
uh and it's a very good point yeah
thanks for coming out it doesn't even
have to be a sub
uh that's also true yeah i'm lying here
because austrian and most resort is more
general than what is data here yes
thank you
so
with
and our research does not assume the
complexity assumption
the unicam's conjecture
so it means that uh
via an earlier result of hostage this
actually means that almost all csps will
be approximation resistant
for a typical constraint satisfaction
problem
of this form you you do not expect to
beat a random assignment randomness is
the best ever form
you can come up with
and uh and this is the main result
that i'm going to tell you in a moment
here are two qualities of our main
result
uh it shows that if we have a csv
instance where each constraint depends
on
exactly k variables
this special case is called max kcsb
then
you cannot hope to approximate better
than you cannot help to satisfy more
than k over to the k fraction of
constraints
if
almost five
uh and this just falls from
our result about pairwise uniform
predicate
uh
if you plug in a predicate given by
samaransky and trevison they came up
with this private key which is
essentially held by code
and
this automatically size mls2k
and you plug it in into our theorem it
shows that you cannot approximate better
than
capable to decay and this measures the
best algorithm
we note
after constant factor
and similarly uh even though this talk
will focus only on the boolean case
everything i said has an analogous
version in
the non-boolean setting and so you also
get a optimal harness result
for csps
when players reply are not boolean
and there are a number of other
applications also
so
for the remainder of this talk i will
sketch a proof of the this main result
if we have
a
prelike this is which is a
p1's uniforms group
then the csp you get
is approximation resistance
uh and as a reminder payments uniform uh
usually you should think of this c is as
the set of strings of even parity
okay
uh the high level idea of the proof is
uh
well we want to prove
an apis result so we have to
start the reduction from free set and
then
to our max csp instance
and
uh
uh one because one other good one a good
starting point
is this label cover form which is known
to be mph
to approximate with a very large
and we'll reduce this to our max csp
instance
i'm going to tell you what label cover
is in in two slides
so don't worry if you don't know what it
is but our strategy is to prove a
labeler for instance
a certain csp whereas uh the players
have purpose strategy we want to map
such an instance into an instance of cs
our our csp instance
uh
with good value
and we also want to map a label cover
instance of bad value into
our csp instance where the players don't
have
non-trivial
strategy
and this is the plan we will do actually
do the reduction in two steps
the first step composition something i
will tell you in a moment and the second
step is this xor step
this xor operational
that i introduced earlier
um
and
here it is crucial that in the second
step uh we will
in in the step in the middle we will get
a csv instance where players have an
almost private strategy we will manage
into an lcsp instance with almost per
strategy it is crucial that uh
c is the subgroup so the player's answer
is still staying as a group
if they have uh yes
okay
so
um
we want to prove the hardness of
transmission result about csps and how
is it related to
kpi games i told you earlier so actually
a kpi game is just another way
of wearing a csp instance
akbar kim will think of a csp instance
as a k-player game where the kps tries
to convince a charge
that's the csp instance is satisfiable
so the judge is unconvinced what can the
judge do the judge pick a random
constraint from our csp instance
and ask for the assignments to
the key variables in the constraint
from key players
then the k uh the players
uh
can just tell the judge okay here's what
i will assign to the first variable in
the constraint board i will assign to
the last variable in the constraint
based on these answers
and together with uh the literals on the
constraint the judge can check
whether players answer
uh the replies from the players will
satisfy the predicate and remember the
predicate is satisfied if uh
if the assignment on the clause
authentication belongs to
this subset c
so again a kpi game is just another
way of viewing
constrained satisfaction problems so and
to prove harness results about csps
we just need to
show that the players don't have a good
strategy to play a game
we are going to
reduce to max usb instance from this
label cover problem that's i'm going to
tell you now
so
a label cover problem is like a
it's a similar game except it's played
uh between two players and judge not k
players and
these two parties uh try to comment
suggest that a certain csp instance is
satisfiable
uh
uh this csv instance will have
large r t that each constraint will
depends on large number of variables
even though i draw
in this example each constraint depends
on only three variables in reality it
will depend on electrons for variables
the player's replies also will not be
boolean
and in this game the labor cover game
uh the judge wants to know whether this
incident is satisfiable so does the
judge pick uh clause say this red cross
at random and that variable
from the cross series blue level
and ask
and ask for assignments from the two
parties one party will
ask uh will answer
any local assignments to all variables
in this clause
this red cross add the party uh party
will answer
the assignments to the
variable
and the judge can check whether the two
players are on us but checking whether
the assignments agree as a variable
and
uh this label cover game
it turns out there is a huge gap in
the winning probability in the estimated
quality of the church
it is npr to decide whether
the cosplayer and the verbal player have
a strategy that always satisfies judge
or if uh
for no matter what the two parties do
the judge will assemble probably close
to zero
and
uh
and this follows by the pcb theorem and
parallel repetition theorem so the
option is there's a huge gap
in
existence property of this game
and we are going to take advantage of
this gap
to transform it into
a huge harness gap in
our csp instance
and we would transform this game
in a composition step that was uh
i think finally nearby hosted
so we want to transform the labor half a
game into an a key player game
uh even though the players are given
boolean replies but they are actually
playing
the labor cover game
uh in disguise
and so we hope to this way we hope to
translate the
huge hundred scale for the book offer
into a hundred scale of our csp instance
so here is how we translate the game uh
now kps want to convince the judge that
there's a successful announcement
to
a csv instance l
the same csp instance in the label cover
instance the judge
start the game by play picking a random
clause and random variable from
from the csv instance l just like labor
cover they just want to know the
satisfaction to the cost and to durable
but instead of asking for
the
assignments to the clause and an
assignment to rebel from the key players
the judge cannot do that because uh
in this max usb game
we want players reply to boolean
to be just a yes no answer so
what we do is uh we will also pick
a subset z1 of satisfied are summoned on
this clause
and ask the first player is the
satisfaction to the cross does it belong
to this subset c1
now the players can just give a boolean
answer yes or no that will be encoding
some information about the citizen
summoner to the clause
likewise for some others
for some of the players the judge will
pick a variable and a set of citizens
fundamental rebels and ask
is the safest assignment to the
variables does it belong to this subset
so the abstract is the player's replies
are all boolean
and
and uh
and now we get the same kpi game as we
saw before
and
so this is a composition step uh
here's something that i didn't tell you
how the choice of the sea ice how do we
choose that and how do we choose the
uh
the negations these bi to bk but uh
i won't go too much into details about
them uh
uh they are chosen according to
something called the tier test
known as study tests in the literature
uh
here i will just say one word uh what
what goes wrong uh if we just do a
composition we saw the xor step that we
introduced earlier the problem is uh
each the question to each player is
across plus a set of variables on a set
of system instruments or a variables
process centralized environment
so
some players will share the same
cost
same uh and other players will share the
same variables this shared information
will allow the players to give an
assignment
that is will not be uniformly random
no matter what uh level of instance you
begin with
so uh this was why
uh
a simple reduction using just
composition will not work and we need
the xor step
okay uh
i will quickly uh finish up uh
i'll quickly tell you the remaining uh
ideas that go into
the composition step
the second step of xor uh
is just what i told you
so in the comments series that we want
to map the level of convinces to a csv
instance where one player's replies is
completely uncredited with other players
reply after negation
uh the condition here just means one
plus replace in front of other players
reply
and
uh here we will use uh
standard tools from harness
approximation
uh
to analyze the composition step and the
tool we use we should uh
we'll show that if the players replies
are
if
the j3s reply is somewhat correlated
with other players reply
then
this they must be somewhat closer on a
strategy and on a strategy of answering
whether
the central assessment to our class is
uh
whether the subject of assignments it's
science to a course belongs to a certain
subset
and
to analyze uh
this result we will use uh the pair is
here where we use the pairwise
uniformity
condition on the constraint and we will
use a powerful tool known as immoran's
principle
and what is the environment principle
an immigrant principle is a
generalization of the central limit
theorem
in central limit theorem we have
n independent plus mass 1 value
variables x 1 to x n if we take the sum
of them and scale down by bridge n
the distribution is just a gaussian
standard gaussian g
and but the standard gaussian is also
the same thing as a sum of n independent
senate gaussian skill boundaries
by the same value whatever regen
so the emergence principle
developed by many people
says that uh it generalized this fact
it says that if we have a low degree
polynomial that does not depends too
heavily on any single coordinate
and if we plug in
plus one independent plasma one speeds
versus independent standard gaussians
the distribution
we get after applying the polymer will
be similar
so centromere theorem is a special case
where the polymer is
summing all the inputs and scale down by
some factor
and
the iran's principle is actually more
general and it applies
uh
when
whenever uh not just tools plus monster
one variables versus gaussian
is applies whenever
the variables have mentioned
first and second moments
and this is here
i won't go into details
but it is here where we use the previous
uniform condition
to argue that we will create creates two
variables they have mentioned moments
and then we can apply the environment
principle
to
to finish the proof to say that uh
our compositions that is sound
okay that's the immense principle and
i i think i should
almost break down
all right i won't go through the details
of uh
why we have
mentioned two moments let me uh
let me finish off by
posting a few open problems
so uh
due to technical reasons uh
the max csp instance that we produce at
the end
will not have a previously will not have
a purpose satisfiable
strategy
so this does not say anything about
hundreds of approximate max csps if the
csp instance is satisfiable to begin
with and
an actual question is what is the
hardness of approximating csp when they
are satisfiable
it seems that substantially newer ideas
are needed to answer this question
and another question i mentioned earlier
is the quadratic inequality and only
obstruction to this xor
step
and finally i think it will be of
interest to the randomize the xor step
right now
if you take the xo of an instance it
will blow up the size of the instance
by a lot
uh
can you work around it can you do a
randomized version of xor and still
achieve
a similar sounders
and
that's it
thank you
so in the second step i mean do you
imagine there's some
uh like maybe the next stop relaxation
of the game which does tensorize and
relaxation is given by
this kind of multiveneer
i tried that i tried thinking in that
direction to prove uh x or lemma uh
so to analysis i show you here do not go
through that do not do relaxation and
you're asking if whether you can do
relaxation and do a second step
uh i just yeah i don't know what would
be the right relaxation maybe it's
possible to to find a relaxation and
and uh
and then prove an excellent whenever
gravitating inequality doesn't apply i
mean yeah whenever you don't have one
perfect quantum strategy
uh
stem might be one way to go to prove a
true x or lemma
the most what if it is just a quantum
value
oh oh i see uh is are you asking uh
maybe
what's the fundamental failure of the
game here or
just like i mean i mean i have no idea
but does i mean the net i mean
is it just what if the quantum value
tensorized oh oh with
oh okay
i believe even that is not known i
believe even even that fact is not found
yeah where did the quantum value test
arise
and uh
also
there are some technical uh
details there uh
quantum people have considered whether
quantum value tends to rise
some maybe some people will consider the
quantum value test rise some people will
consider whether quantum value using
only these restricted costs of creations
uh
uh research costs of
entangled states that's rise
and
i think both forms is are probably
open
whether when
the players are allowed
arbitrary quantum values
and the players are allowed only this
regional class of an entitled state
the value of the quantum game will be
tenderized i think both are open yeah
you i guess
uh you you cannot hope to
get
from point nine you you eventually you
it should converge to coordinate of c or
two to the k
so you should only look at xr games so
that the you want to get to zero instead
of getting to some
uh yes yeah uh right yeah we will we
yeah certainly uh so so you would want
to show this excellent only for exam
games
right uh so by x or games uh do you mean
the smallest private k of of
yeah the predicate is an excerpt it's an
xor because that that means you go to
zero instead of going to some
point i suppose zero of correlation uh
yes oh i see yes uh well yeah but maybe
yeah uh i see yeah that's right or maybe
you can hope for a stronger version
where
uh you want all fourier coefficients to
be to go to zero or not travel for
equations equal to zero starting with
the assumption that all fourier
coefficients are bound away from one
you you can also ask those kind of
questions so not necessarily it's a game
you yeah a lot about this question you
know if now you each you have one small
three i mean each period coefficient is
small in one of the games right yes
and uh
uh and if that they're just smaller than
one did you
i
i believe so uh
i think it should be possible to prove
that uh
after the composition step the quantity
of the game should be bound away from
one i think if you might be able to
prove that
uh
i mean at least with with this ghc
states so quarterback when when the
players can only use gst states the
value i think you can prove that is
boundary from one but then i don't know
how to carry out the second step to
prove a
true excellent to boost the harness
yeah i i yeah i spent some time on it
and i don't know
how to prove that
you're
yes because
you have just a single constraint yes
and actually
well it's not exactly that you have a
single constraint of a single constraint
shift like yes also a loudly throws yeah
yeah
so
like is there like a chance to address
like any other type of constraint
families like for instance when you
really have a single constraint
but maybe no literals or i better find
them but uh no literals
but don't need to roll instance or
like a logic or
like other types of constraints
so
uh yes first this is a very natural
question to go
natural direction to go
and
uh
so the technique here is really
i think you can uh okay uh
the general situation i think will be
quite complicated yeah the technique
here would not be able to address the
general situation uh like what you said
and even removing the literals uh
so technically it will not work yeah i
think substantially new ideas is needed
to to answer those questions
uh and the reason is because uh we
we start the relationship from labor
coffer and
labor forum is very restrictive
10 15.